how do you work with actors
i have a great time working with actors
and
pretty much all the actors i've worked
with still like me so that's a good sign
i when i'm working with actors i really
try to focus on the early stages one is
just getting them to feel comfortable
with
me because they're putting a lot of
faith in me as a director
that i'm going to steer them in the
right direction that i know what i'm
talking about uh
you know every actor especially you know
um people are starting out or
or uh that do a lot of supporting work
so many of them get thrown into these
just
terrible movies where they're almost
ashamed they were part of it
and so they're putting a lot of faith in
me as a director and as a writer that
you know that
i'm going to deliver for them and so
kind of get them comfortable let them
know kind of my vision
who i see their character as what i see
it saying
all that but then i work with them to
feel really comfortable
with their understanding of the
character even before we get into lines
um really talking with them who did they
see their character as
what is you know when the character does
this in a scene do you have any
questions about that or is there any
questions you have about your character
um i really want them to feel like they
know that
person and that therefore when they're
playing them they're not they're not
thinking about
notes they had there's nothing worse i
mean
there's a lot of a actor's process and
each of them has their own process
someone write a very complicated chart
that tracks their character's arc and
their choices throughout the whole
film which is great because you want you
know if that's how they do it you want
them to feel like they know their
character and they understand it they
can see the whole thing
but the last thing you want to see is
when they're performing you don't want
to see them thinking about those notes
you want them to be living in the moment
and so
getting to the point where they trust
they know the character
that's when i know i have i have a good
performance once we get to that stage i
start feeling really good about it
um you know when we're doing fray brian
uh we walked worked on his walk for days
getting his walk down to where you could
see that he had the physical wound but
you can also see he was trying to hide
it
um him spending that time with those uh
those veterans was a huge breakthrough
for him it changed his
his own personal perspective on it he
actually said to me after that he said
because i was really excited about this
movie because it's an incredible role
and i
you know really feel like it's a great
opportunity for me as an actor
but after meeting these guys he's like i
all i can think about now is i just hope
i can do their story justice
and that to me was when it changed it
became for him it wasn't about
playing a role it became real to him
he saw the lives that those guys had and
obviously i couldn't do that with the
vampire film but part of it with them
was you know the casting vania's from
serbia
gabby's from hungary
and so they come from the worlds that
these vampires are from
they had that folklore and stuff growing
up so i was a big part of it already
naturally their accent is there
so we have to come up with some cheesy
dracula accent
but then helping them understand and
find those connections that they have to
them personally
and then from there creating onset
an environment where they feel safe to
take risks to not feel like if they flub
a line that i'm going to
be upset with them and
for vania part of it he's an amazing
talent but english isn't his first
language
you know he struggled with some of my
dialogues to let allow him the freedom
to make it his own and some of his
improv in it and some of the lines he
came up with was so much better than i
wrote
uh he has some throwaway lines that i up
that still make me laugh and i've seen
the film a thousand times now
uh so allowing them to really
personalize it and make it themselves
and not feeling like as the writer
director that i'm losing my vision
because they're taking something in a
new way it's almost like okay let's go
for this ride let's see where they take
me now and i just find like that just
helps it's again it's empowering to them
keeps them from feeling like they're
walking on eggshells that you know
worrying about making a mistake
but then also not being afraid to
correct them if something's really
you know the choice isn't right having
that conversation
catching them early on it feeling like
you know again if you have that trust
they're going to respect when i speak up
and i'm like no that's not how
how your character would go we can have
that discussion they can understand why
um had that with vania had that with
gabby had that with brian have had that
with all my actors where you have that
moment where it's like
you know it's great i like what you were
trying to do there but let's think about
it from this perspective of why your
character wouldn't do that
and i always say if i can't justify a
choice it's not the right choice
so with any actor i always have that
justification otherwise let them do it
their way
if i'm going to give them a note there's
going to be a reason for it otherwise i
want them to feel like
they've got it what are the pros and
cons of working with non-actors you know
you see movies sometimes let's say
winners bone
where you're like you know what those
are real people it seems like for the
most part in the background
and it really lends to the film and just
from watching the trailer of fray
i think you had said that there were
non-actors in it but i
i could it really made me feel like i
was there
in a town a small town logging area it's
for for any film i think it's it can be
great if you want to if you want to have
authenticity
just use the real people uh
it makes a world of difference because
you know
great character actors can embody
interesting characters for sure
uh but there is still something
different
from an actor playing somebody like that
versus the real person that's their life
and that's what they do
um so authenticity is the greatest
attribute of it
um for a low budget film you know
there's no way on a movie like that i
was able to cast
and afford uh 30 great extras
or with or you know supporting roles
stuff like that like
i can only bring in so many people and i
would rather have somebody who's
real and maybe not the best actor
versus a bad actor who's not real
um you know if you through like the uh
there's a scene where he's interviewing
for a job at a dairy queen
and becky was the actual manager of that
dairy queen
who does the scene in the interview now
she just had to be herself she was doing
an actual job interview it just happened
to be on camera
and she was nervous and everything but
we got her comfortable and she did it
and
and with non-actors i don't give them
dialogue i give them point a and point b
now just be you and then the actor you
know brian was great at impro
improv so he could go with it he could
roll with it he knew things he had to
get across so he would steer it that way
so that's part of having a very talented
actor to work with that can steer a
scene
like that with becky i was like okay
you're interviewing him
he's got to have these qualifications
you've got to ask him about this
and then just do a normal interview and
then trust also you can pull it off and
editing and make it work
so that was a big thing and one of my
favorite moments from that was when
la weekly put out the review they ended
the review
quoting becky she actually had a line in
that
that when when she said it i was just
like that's better than anything i will
ever write
it was a question she asks him what do
you think qualifies you to work
this establishment and he retorts back
well you know i did five tours of duty
here but i don't see how that'll help me
at it you know and uh
her response back is well it can be a
battlefield in here sometimes especially
during the summer
i'm just like i would have never thought
of that and that's the greatest answer
to that line
to that ever um and i love the fact that
this woman who's a manager at a dairy
queen in the coastal mountains of oregon
was literally quoted in la weekly
so that's that's the beauty of having a
non-actor is they can bring that level
of realness to
that's their daily life and so if you
just let them be themselves
but that's the hard part as a director
is you can't
you can't direct them you literally give
them
um the scenario and then just trust them
to be themselves
and then hopefully you get what you need
out of it
so you're also not getting a lot of
takes uh you do more than two or three
takes they start getting self-conscious
and then you've lost them
you